hello sal here from khan academy welcome
to our homeroom live stream have a very
exciting guest today uh but before we
jump into that conversation i will give
my standard reminders to folks one uh
just a reminder that we are a
not-for-profit organization the work
that khan academy does is only possible
because of philanthropic donations from
folks like yourself so if you're in a
position to do so please think about
making a donation you can go to
khanacademy.org donate also want to make
a special shout out to several
organizations that when they realized
that we were already running at a
deficit precovid and in order to support
frankly the world
through the school closures
we were running an even larger deficit
special thanks to bank of america
google.org att fastly in novartis and
the amgen foundation for stepping up and
helping us close that gap although we
are still running a gap so any support
at any level for khan academy if you're
in the position to do so it allows for a
lot of other folks who aren't in the
position to do so to continue to keep
learning especially as we're going
through these uh very very hard times
so with that i'm super excited to
introduce our guest
maria elena salinas for many of y'all
she is probably an icon someone that you
grew up with uh for some of y'all she
might be a relatively new name but uh
for those of you all say that she's an
icon for many po folks uh she anchored
univision for many decades she's a
contributor to cbs news really one of
the um iconic journalists uh in the
world uh maria thanks so much for for
joining us
thank you so much self for that very
kind introduction and saludo
in espanol that's uh hello to those of
us who are listening in spanish who are
watching in spanish yeah and thanks for
that because today we do have our our
spanish speaking there's a fully spanish
version versus there's a fully spanish
version of khan academy es.khan
academy.org and we're also posting this
on our spanish language sites so yes
uh excited to have i know it is there
that's really good let's continue
learning
exactly exactly on the screen
so so there's two things i really want
to talk about today obviously we're
we're we're having this conversation in
very sub-optimal times we're going
through a pandemic that pandemic has
helped impact it has an economic impact
it's having an education impact and it
and it does look like it's
disproportionately affecting
the latinx community
especially in the united states so i
definitely want to talk about that and i
also want to make sure we have time to
talk about your journey which i find
very inspiring and i think a lot of
young people watching will find
inspiring as well but let's start i
guess maybe on the
you know the world that we're in right
now you recently did a documentary on
the the pandemic and how it's affecting
uh the latinx community in particular
what were your you know what are the big
headlines from that what were your big
takeaways what did you learn from that
well for one thing i'm very happy that
cbs decided to to do this special i
don't think it was enough to do just do
one two minute three-minute stories in
in their newscasts and their regularly
scheduled programs
but it was important and it was
important also that we had a full latino
staff all the reporters producers
researchers bookers or all latinos
because you know there's a
relativity that we have to the subject
and to the community we know our
community better than anyone else and i
think you know the big headlines out of
that really is that you said it we are
disproportionately being affected by
this pandemic latinos are getting sick
in higher numbers latinos are dying in
higher numbers latinos are losing their
jobs in higher numbers or making less
money
there are the essential workers that
keep the economy going and
you know while they do have a job
they're risking their lives and many of
them don't qualify for unemployment they
don't qualify for
a stimulus check
so they're being affected i think in
economically
um and and also um you know health-wise
they're they're being very very affected
and it's not getting better it's getting
worse unfortunately
and what's what do you think are the
main levers that are causing this
inequity and then what what do you think
can be done to at least less and
hopefully eliminate some some of these
issues
well it's the historical inequities that
have been
really exacerbated by the pandemic
poverty
um unemployment
um
you know insufficient um insufficient
savings i think uh there was one study
that said that more than half of latinos
had only 500 or less in their savings
uh lack of access to adequate health
care
all these traditional inequities or
historical inequities they they just got
worse during this time and when it comes
to education
a subject that i know that you're
passionate about and that has become
your mission and your passion
latino kids are staying behind more than
than others more than any others and
that is because only one in three latino
households has access to internet and
only half of them about 50 percent have
enough computers at home nothing they
don't have computers they don't have
enough computers
the majority of essential workers do the
types of jobs that you can't do at home
from the comfort of your home in a zoom
box so they do have to go out and work
but the ones that do have to rely on a
computer and if they have two or three
kids they don't have enough and even
though
school districts across the country have
been
distributing computers laptops or
tablets to kids around the country it
hasn't been enough this morning there
was an article in the los angeles times
that talked precisely about that point
and said that in california alone uh
kids need more than a million
um computers to be able to go back to
school and study from home
now in this last point obviously as you
know this has been something that we've
at khan academy we've been very focused
on uh throughout the pandemic even
pre-pandemic uh around the divide and
you know there's
exactly right there's the education
issue there's the economic issue and
then there's the healthcare issue and
maybe we'll we'll start with the
education issue just where you let left
off what do you think we can do because
yeah i'm seeing the same thing when we
talk to district officials we talk to
educators even where there have been
heroic efforts to get a lot of laptops
out there they're still losing a lot of
kids and these kids are
disproportionately students of color
a lot of their parents as you mentioned
they might be essential workers they're
the folks that are making sure that we
can get our groceries they're the folks
that are making sure uh that other
things are up and running and so these
kids are a little are are less supported
but you know personally i've been at a
loss of of knowing what the solution is
what can we do
you know obviously on our level we're
trying as much as possible hey khan
academy's there if you have internet
access if you have a device even a cell
phone use us that's something but what
else can we do should we think about as
a society
well you're right latino parents are
very concerned in fact um a recent
survey by latino decisions that focuses
only on latino
voters or latino families says that 53
percent are really thinking of not
sending their kids back to school now a
great majority say that they wish they
could go back to school but that the
only way that they would send them back
is if there were precautions such as
making sure that the classroom is clean
and and such as making sure that they're
aware that they're wearing masks and
taking the necessary precautions there
um and uh
83 are concerned that their kids
will be
left behind in their studies and that is
a real concern but you know when you
think about kids
and going back to school and wearing
masks and taking all the necessary
precautions i mean i i
see it all the time i have two daughters
and i have two stepdaughters my two
stepdaughters are both teachers one of
them teaches second grade and the other
one teaches at the university level
the one that teaches second grade you
know tells me you know you sit in a
class and not to have kids on top of
each other hitting each other teasing
each other or having them wear a mask to
make sure that the mask is over their
nose is virtually impossible to do now
she is only 32 years old she might not
be at very high risk but her husband has
diabetes
he's had he has childhood diabetes if
she gets sick and takes the home her
husband can die so
these are the things that we need to
think about and my other
step-daughter who teaches at the
university level she teaches journalism
at ucf
same thing they are doing virtual
classes and she'll be going in to teach
once a week however she has a
seven-year-old son who's in second grade
and he's doing virtual classes and she
will not let him go to school
because she's very afraid
that that he would get sick because she
has a little baby so you know every
family has their story every family has
a set of circumstances
that makes them more vulnerable you know
what the solution would be of course for
everyone to have access to the necessary
technology so that they can study from
home
so that the kids can continue learning
from home and maybe some of those school
districts who don't have cases that are
that serious maybe begin going back
little by little with taking all of
these precautions but it really is scary
how this has turned into a political
issue this isn't a matter of
red and blue this is a matter of life
and death
so it's it's really sad
and it's dangerous also for for this to
happen i live in miami
and in florida
the governor is
forcing
schools to go back in person to have
in-person classes
otherwise he threatens with withholding
state funds now when the president said
he would withhold federal funds well you
think it's only maybe five ten percent
of their budget but the state funds are
a little bit more so it you know it
would be detrimental to to school
districts
yeah i think there's several things
you're touching on there one is the
school opening issue and uh yesterday we
had the head of the nea
the largest teachers union and last week
we had the head of the nfd and you know
this is one of those situations where
regardless of you know sometimes these
things in education turn very political
but this is just a basic health and
safety issue and any
epidemiologist that you talk to will
tell you
if if there's a high incidence in a
community right now to
put kids put 30 kids in a not so well
ventilated place and a teacher uh who
may or may not be at high risk
themselves but they're going to have
family members that could be at high
risk it's actually just not even good
for those people directly involved it's
bad for the whole community because a
pandemic you have to you have to keep
it's going to hurt all of us who aren't
even going to school uh because it'll
just create more spread in the community
what you know i've seen some good
examples actually the head of the nea
yesterday talked about marilyn doing a
good job of where even where kids don't
you know they're going to distance
learning
which seems appropriate given where we
are in the pandemic but for those kids
who need those extra supports at home
who might you know maybe their parents
an essential worker and can't support
the kid while they're during the school
day they are opening the schools up for
a few of them in a very careful way but
they're still doing distance learning
from school but they're getting some
kind of child care and they're getting
some support from some adults is are you
seeing
programs that you think are helping i
would say especially the latinx
community but just in general
communities that need extra supports
right now or are you are you kind of
discouraged by
the state of affairs right now
i do see a lot of of of help and you
know in lieu of having our governments
at all levels help these kids you do see
philanthropists stepping up and helping
um
with different programs and helping
families with food helping families
maybe pay their rent and also in this
case helping families distribute
computers
people are very kind and they always try
to help you know we shouldn't
underestimate the kindness of the
american people there was one um case of
a family that i covered also for cbs
earlier um this year just a couple of
months ago where these three little boys
the hernandez boys they
had only two computers one that was
provided by
the school another one that they had at
home and then the third boy who was
eight years old had to do his homework
on his father's phone and that created a
problem only because it's very difficult
for you to do
homework on on a phone uh als not to
mention the fact that
the data would be more expensive for
this family
when the father is unemployed because he
lost his job uh because of covid and and
the mother is is a housewife she stays
home taking care of the kids so when
when we heard this story
uh i have so many tweets of people
wanting stepping up and wanting to help
and wanting to donate a computer to
these kids and and finally one person
did get in touch with the family and did
send
the little boy an extra laptop but you
know we have to rely on the kindness of
our neighbors of organizations um so
that we can
have this but
let's say that we get enough computers
out there that would get enough laptops
and that some philanthropy says okay we
need a million in la in in california
we're going to give them a million
there's also the issue of of having
access to wi-fi
in texas for example there was one area
where there was a school bus that was
retrofitted to become a wi-fi hotspot uh
going to communities where they knew
that these families these these
low-income families didn't have access
to it uh there were some families that
told us that they have to get in the car
and drive to the parking lot of a
mcdonald's or or a walmart or another
store so that they're able to use those
hot spots
that is a serious issue that's a serious
problem and i don't know what what the
solution is i mean they said money is it
is it always that we throw money into
things and then they they get solved um
you know money does help
but in this case it's going to be it
takes a lot more you know i i
interviewed a teacher of these three
hernandez boys that i mentioned to you
and she told me that her main concern
was not the fact that they might stay
behind she says they're smart kids
they're young enough where they will
eventually catch up she was worried
about their security she was worried
that
if they're not in school
that maybe they live in in areas that
might be a little dangerous and they go
out on the streets and put themselves in
danger or that because the parents go
home the older kids have to take care of
their younger siblings therefore don't
have
the ability of spending enough time and
having enough attention uh to the
classes that that are being given online
yeah it's a super tough situation you
know we had dr fauci on a couple of a
couple weeks ago and you know when we
played out how this all might work and
you know i've talked to other folks who
are
very well steeped in the epidemiology of
of the pandemic
it looks like the best case scenario is
that we're looking at a unusual
circumstance that we're in maybe for
another 9 10 or 12 you know the next
year and there's even some probability
it goes beyond the next year if some of
these early vaccines don't work out and
so given that let's just say we're
looking at a year of um
you know a health crisis a year of a lot
of service industries being really
difficult uh you know restaurant
transportation travel
and a year of some form of distance or
hybrid learning what do you where do you
think this is going to leave us uh a
year from now if we're having the same
conversation what do you think is is
going to happen to society and
especially a lot of the populations a
lot of the folks that that you've been
working with over over the last many
decades
um you know i think they're going to be
hurting very much you know people keep
saying we're all in this together
and we're on the same boat but we're not
it's the same storm but we're in
different boats
some are in yachts others are in
sailboats and others are in rickety
little little boats that can easily turn
over and and we have to take into
consideration that not everyone uh can
survive this not everyone can have
homeschooling or
special tutors
so i you know it affects everyone we're
talking mostly about kids right now but
when you talk about businesses that will
not be able to survive uh families that
will not be able to pay the rent uh even
though there was a moratorium on on rent
uh there's so many families that can
become homeless
if those that moratorium doesn't extend
for several more months or whatever is
needed in some states like california
that has been extended by the by the
governor but
it can happen and you also have to think
of of the landlords well you know
they're paying that also there are some
landlords that might have multiple homes
and there's some that might be depending
only on the rent of of that person in
order to be able to pay their own bills
so it's a domino effect
that doesn't have to be and i think
that's what's the most frustrating thing
if everyone just cooperated and everyone
followed the rules
this would be over so much faster you
know we see we see the new zealand we
see it in countries that that took
action early on
and and didn't open up too fast and also
i think another problem that we have
here in the united states is that
there's no uniformity um
it's not only the you know it's not only
that the federal government doesn't have
uh any specific regulations or mandates
it's that
they vary state by state and even within
the state they vary county by county
so what do you do i mean how how do you
solve a problem when um it might be
better in the area where you live
and maybe your neighboring area is is
much worse or maybe better and do you
move there and create another uh housing
crisis
it's you know i do see it as a major
problem and you're right it could go on
a lot longer um i know my daughters and
i who are working from home they're 23
and 25 and you know we've
realized that the right we have to think
that at least the rest of this year this
is the way it's going to be instead of
worrying every day and every week is
this going to be over do we have you
know is it going to be next week or the
week after the month after let's just
assume that the rest of the year this is
the way that we're going to live
but in but it could happen beyond that
like you say it could very well happen
beyond that and we have to prepare for
this i think it's going to take a
catastrophe to shake us up and say okay
we got to do something maybe it's going
to take a complete shutdown of the
country in order for us god willing no
wear some wood knock on wood let's hope
that doesn't happen
but if it's necessary then then it
should happen
because we can't go on like this
it's it it's just hurting everyone
every single person is being hurt by
this especially
families and families absolutely
and it's definitely there's levers that
are you know out of you're my controls
uh but as you mentioned the the the
federal and the state level pandemic
response we have patterns other other
countries quicker testing etc and then
you know what are the economic
safeguards which it does you know you
bring up a good point it's not just a
moratorium on evictions or or rent you
know the landlords some of them are also
very vulnerable so you have to go
through the whole system all the way
through the the banks and the financing
system and whatever else i'm getting a
ton of questions here on social media
this first one from chris young from
facebook he's a high school teacher new
to esl new to english as a second
language he's asking what are my
must-dos to better to be better at
including my hispanic community
well yeah you know i'm glad that that
you brought that up because
some of the most vulnerable are also
kids that are taking esl classes and
kids that have special needs
um how do you get to them i mean without
that personal contact uh you know what
do you tell this teacher the most
important thing is is
even if they have to be if there's to be
less hours of learning
there needs to be consistency uh the
kids need to feel that it's something
important they need to feel that they're
doing something important and that it's
making a difference
so i think that consistency
um is going to help them understand not
to get discouraged you know it might
take a lot longer for them to to learn
um but it's better for to take longer
than for them not to be learning at all
so you know whatever
esl
teachers can do you know make an extra
effort because they have extra needs
to teach these kids online
and to keep them engaged
and and and make them interested and and
understanding
um that
that it's important for them to do this
every single day even if it's on
weekends you know why not yeah to
actually to actually stay engaged it
seems like the name of the game right
now and make sure they have not just the
academic yeah the social engagement
there's a question here this is you know
this is actually a really interesting
question that i'll broaden a little bit
from youtube dave hankins says maria has
a journalist reporting on what's going
on how do you feel about the
misinformation that's being spread about
kovid that's not necessarily based on
science or reality i have noticed that
many people are still in denial about
how serious it really is and will
continue to be and i'll i'll broaden
that question um even broader than kovid
because it seems like the nature of
media has somewhat changed over the last
few decades where it feels like it's
more polarized that you know people talk
a lot about social media where you can
kind of be in your own bubble and only
kind of hear what you want to hear but
it also feels like that has happened
even in the mainstream media where you
know you can watch the channels uh that
kind of feed your own viewpoint and you
know i i've at least read things in the
media that you know some of the
incentives even in the media houses seem
to be much more focused about just
purely engaging folks and getting them
hooked versus
you know giving the the middle of the
road information that that may not
necessarily be what they want to hear
but it's actually closer to the the
truth
how do you view that how do you view the
evolution of media are you seeing the
same types of trends and and how do you
think we can get to a world where you
know the media is playing that that that
role is that fourth estate the
institution that kind of makes sure that
we all have good information and holds
us accountable
exactly that's the role of the media to
seek the truth to denounce and justice
and and um and corruption um yet uh we
are being threatened um and
in i think it also threatens democracy i
mean the media is a pillar of of
democracy
um it's one of the pillars of democracy
i should say um you know i think it's
very dangerous when people don't believe
the media and i understand what you're
saying that the media is also divided
and and you have and i think this is
especially true when you have these
24-hour
news channels
where they had 24 hours to fill with all
this information
and also the trend that started a few
years ago of not only journalists uh
presenting shows on these 24-hour show
networks but also
uh people that are not journalists
people that are commentators
uh people that are celebrities or
commentators they're not journalists so
if you see someone sitting behind a desk
reading
with graphics on the side to you they
look like any anchor any journalist that
is reporting and it's not necessarily so
they are doing commentary they are
giving their opinion uh which is
something that a journalist doesn't do
but if you watch abccbs and nbc news
you're going to see something very
different uh i think that's where you
get most of your information but then
you have half an hour uh only
and out of that half an hour it's really
only 22 minutes of information
of the whole world because of the
commercial break so there's very little
time for that so i think you know
really people need to
to do their research you know they need
to that's their responsibility
also to be out there to read as many
sort different sources as they can
um
i know in my social media some people
say oh
i'm not gonna listen to the media i'm
going to listen to the experts
and then you think okay how are they
going to listen to the experts if it's
not through the media because the expert
is not going to call you up or send you
an email and tell you
this is the way things are you know what
an expert is going to do is have a press
conference and and make sure that the
media has the information that they can
relay
to the people but
um to those affected uh but but it does
worry me all these conspiracy theories i
mean you see very smart intelligent
people believing some of these
conspiracy theories and you know i think
it happens all the time we have 350
million i think people in the in the
country and we have 160 something
thousand that have died so if it doesn't
so the great majority of people are not
affected by this
um they
don't maybe not know
someone who has gotten sick or or who
has died so if it doesn't affect you you
don't believe it but the moment it does
the moment you have someone in your
family getting sick or dying is
that's what it takes for you to take
this seriously
um
you know and i don't know that there's
anything we can do about that honestly i
wish there was a a response
i wish i could tell you this is the
secret sauce this is
the secret to to everybody paying
attention and listening and believing
but that's not gonna happen people
you know have have these conspiracy
theories and they're going to continue
to have these conspiracy theories no
matter
how much you tell them that it's not
true but it's very dangerous it's very
very dangerous
i mean to your point something like the
crisis we're in it might be like that
type of reality where at some point
those opinions don't matter anymore
because at some point you do know folks
i mean i just in our broader friend
circle we know at least two people
who've actually passed away from kovid
um and and so i'm guessing it is going
to start hitting a lot a lot more folks
i mean related to that have you seen
like when you talk to journalists people
you've been working with for decades
do they feel like
yeah you know it's the good old days the
good old days we were all about you know
getting the information out there we
weren't as concerned with you know
hooking people in we could you know it
wasn't just about sound bites while now
it's much shorter it's all about
grabbing attention is there that trend i
mean that's i obviously i've i've asked
that in a somewhat biased way that's at
least my perception of how things have
evolved yeah
well you know in local news there's a
saying that if it bleeds it leads
um which means that yeah most media
especially local media always looks at
something that can grab you why because
people have the option of watching um
different channels
and you want to grab them from the
beginning and you know that just goes to
tell you that people are very curious i
don't want to use the word morbid
but usually those that are more
sensationalists are the ones that have
the highest ratings people want to watch
and then they say i don't want to know i
don't want to know but i'm watching i
mean that happens all the time
i do think that we wish we were in the
good old days where we were reporting
news and and not being
questioned the way there we are
questioned now i'll tell you one thing
that really affects people is is the
rhetoric
against uh the media mainstream media
coming from the highest levels of
government um and you know i worked in
spanish language media for decades like
like you mentioned at the beginning
and we know
we've covered a lot of authoritarian
governments in in latin america and we
know that authoritarian governments what
they do is one of the first things they
do is try to silence the media uh they
either
kill them for example like in
khashoggi's case or they
close down their their business or they
put the put them in jail
they do anything that they can to
silence them i know recently i was in
nicaragua and the way they tried to
silence the media there is by um kind of
forcing them to go digital because they
they put a special tax on importing uh
the products to publish the newspaper
the paper the ink uh the equipment and
then
another way of doing it is calling them
the enemy of the people it's by
discrediting um journalism and
discrediting journalists you know i
sometimes
watch
these 24-hour news that say i watch cnn
quite a bit
and i'm astonished when i see some of
these journalists that i've been
watching for years that i know are very
good journalists that i know are i
shouldn't say objective because
objectivity doesn't exist anymore that
are balanced that that give perspective
because that's what journalists are
supposed to be doing constantly
fact-checking they're spending their
whole
time on the air fact-checking
fact-checking fact-checking
fact-checking and and playing devil's
advocate against
people the non-believers
and you know i think
what's happening now has pushed people
to be that way
um
but i still think it's a noble
profession
i'm
still very honored to to be a journalist
and i still do believe that our
profession is is a profession that we
need to be proud of and that you know we
are there to serve the public we are
there we are the only barrier between
those in power and those that they are
trying to reach
um
so if we weren't so important they
wouldn't be trying to silence us
completely agree and and as you point
out you know now with social media where
anyone can publish anything to have
professionals who are really going after
facts uh i think couldn't be more
important than any other point in
history uh well maria you know whenever
we're having these interesting
conversations the time goes way faster
than i ever expect i could talk to you
for hours
but i just really wanted to thank you on
my behalf and the whole khan academy
team and all the viewers we have for
joining us i think we learned a lot and
i hope we can do this again
thank you so much sal i really
appreciate the opportunity and sorry
sometimes i tend to talk too much and go
on and on and on but you know these are
issues that i'm passionate about i know
that you are too
and i i thank you on behalf of the
latino community for also having this
sigmo
and making sure that that
students of of different nationalities
in the country in the world um have
some kind of support so that they can
you know continue so they can get ahead
education is one of the most important
things that we can have
and i think that
everyone is very well aware of that and
in our case in the latino community
immigrant families know that
education is the only way their kids
won't have to go through what they went
through in order to get ahead so thank
you so much for what you do
thank you
well everyone thanks so much for for
joining today's live stream you know
every time i i think we're like 10
minutes into it and we i realize i'm 31
minutes into it because uh there's so
much to talk about but i hope you
enjoyed the conversation today with
maria as much as i did uh look forward
to more of these conversations uh we're
going to have uh lester holt on tomorrow
uh and uh i think we'll actually be able
to continue to some degree this
conversation about the media and also
you know i always find it interesting
because you know journalists report on
what's going on in the world but these
are also very thoughtful folks who are
uh seeing aspects of society in the
world that many of us don't get to see
and so i think they really form really
interesting perspectives about you know
the the context that we're in and maybe
ways to to get out of them or make them
better uh but once again thanks so much
for joining and i will see you all
tomorrow
you